introducing first with a record Oh one
win three defeats representing of the
real rejects channel on youtubes gray
and John they're here yeah did he break
the TV that's all I care about
it might have been worth it if it did
that would have been worse that's gonna
be slow-motion that's gonna be means
that might be the highlight of their
night it might be if that is their
highlight as that was impressed for the
answer
hey guys Greg Alba here Andrew here and
you're from the movie source channel who
rarely reviews movie trailers with me
he's gonna do one today you and we're
gonna shoot the defender series review
in a second but right now we're gonna do
the trailer for brawl and cellblock 99
from the director of bone bone hawk
tomahawk but ever don't don't bone
tomahawk that's what's called Tom boat
Octomom the Vince Vaughn thumbnail he's
bulbs that means he can play Lex Luthor
means you can play like Luthor you just
have to be bowling it was a cool title I
do like I like that a lot maybe he's
Wilson Fisk inside that prison
oh he's balding you know you can be it's
crazy see Vince Vaughn's were trained
like drama lately huh yeah he's not
raised not playing the same character
over and over I like it damn it they're
crazy tattoo
[Music]
well I see man that sure that just means
to be on this side of the table I'm also
just for sure we can still here at
Howard or stone Oh
[Music]
tell me what you got an American flag
only probably got
oh you a patriot that car and a thief or
now is that baby spying something
underwater
my name's Jim Carrey's best likes little
music choice Don Johnson Louise I do
things direct here and Prison will give
me plenty of time looking guys I don't
like marriage
uh surprisingly really cool actually
Vince Vaughn's I was already seem
excited seeing that he's stepping more
in a dramatic territory again lately I
was fascinated here and finally speaking
you're like oh he's doing an accent in
this movie this characters a former
boxer and like it wouldn't heat when
he's moving he's moving like a legit
boxer he's moving like an actual fighter
I can't think of when Vince Vaughn was
an actual badass in a movie who could
fight and so I'm excited to see him
doing that I like when these older
actors take the time to become action
heroes and it seems like he's going down
that path here it has sort of this
Western sort of feels a little bit like
Gran Torino just a little bit and that
moment too when he's beating up the [ __ ]
out of that car like for a prison
fighter damn who wanna [ __ ] with that
guy the guy who beats up a car dude
you're crazy he reminded me so much of
the character he was honing in on
wedding crashers when he's when he's
beating the [ __ ] out of that car kind of
visually reminded me a little bit of
Terminator 3 rise of the machines where
Arnold just beats honing in his t
hundred right now watching him do that
was just making me cringe like on my
knuckles cuz that looks like it hurts
a lot just punching straight up titanium
metal the part that got me if you notice
interaction when we both said no it's
like when we see the hand the
hand-to-hand combat but that looked
committed look like Vince Vaughn is
trained and able to fight like that
those are the things I appreciate the
most when you watch like the matrix it
feels like Nia like Keanu Reeves can
fight when you watch Iron Fist it
doesn't fully feel like Dana or like
Finn Jones can fully fight with
especially the cuts in the camera from a
fight choreography standpoint which you
and me I know that's very important of
the camera staying still really letting
us in on the action so we feel really a
part of it that these actors like yours
it feels like a defining part of this
character his fighting style and the way
like it's called brawl and cellblock
1990 he looks like the kind of guy who
could brawl like we don't really get
much details there's really get details
which I'd like for a good teaser trailer
we don't really get to know Jennifer
carpenters character is under then the
woman he loves and I like Jennifer
Carpenter a lot seen every episode of
Dexter really like torn Exorcism of
Emily Rose actually was in quarantine
Tori yeah Don Johnson's a really
guy to having this kind of film to do we
get a good sense of tone visual imagery
a sense for the Vince Vaughn character
this really feels like even though it's
from the director of bone tomahawk it
feels like the main strength of this
film was gonna really rely on the
performance by Vince Vaughn oh
definitely seems like he's gonna deliver
the first shot we get him the back of
the head with that tattoo I already was
serious yeah I'm hoping and I'm glad
they didn't show us in the show that we
really get invested in a way not not
rooting for this character but
understanding his motivations and why
he's doing what he's doing massenet ting
officers ya know and I and I love that
they didn't give any kind of hint really
to that in this trailer because it has
more of the mystery sense obviously the
action scenes are what I'm probably
looking most forward to I'm also looking
at the character exploration seeing it
like going into the mind of this guy who
seems insane to be punching this car
yeah yeah I mean felt like Street
Fighter 2 when you just punch the car
watch the car I can't wait to like find
out the psychology of this guy what's
going on through his head because like
the performance seems very interesting
and it seems like a territory where
Vince Vaughn has not gone and in a while
because again in my mind I'm gotten I
haven't watched the will we know more
for the comedy you know Fred Claus
wedding crashers all all those I think
you're right the strength of this film
is gonna rely on his performance how
invested we get in this character not
only from from a mental perspective but
just understanding like the the fight
choreography and all of that like that's
gonna be a big part of is the actually
gonna dictate some part of the story so
I'm really this like again this little
2-3 minute tease or whatever it was it
really got me interested and I think the
biggest part is the psychology and the
mystery to this character which I'm
looking most forward to I'm looking
forward to it man
all right well thanks for sitting on our
way guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
keep a look out for our defenders
reviews please follow and you're on the
movie source channel on YouTube egg or
7-eleven on Twitter and Instagram and
check out our patreon become a patron
eject today loving it over there take
care guys